- I do not want to go skiing.
I do not want to go to a beer garden.
It is not fun for me
to go look at a museum.
I am not interested in watching Netflix.
I am not interested.
(dramatic music)
- Hey!
- [Man] You got more perspective.
(dramatic music)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(inspirational music)
- [Interviewer] When
you're working with family
how do you balance the love
that you guys have for
each other with, you know,
getting tough feedback
when the time comes?
- Yeah, it's the most difficult thing.
You know, business is business,
and family is family.
And those are two, you know,
blood is thicker than water, you know.
These are unbelievable difficult things.
To me it's like a 50.0, 50.1.
It's not even 51-49 that
I like to throw around.
Family businesses are more 50.1 to 49.9
where you have to be all about the family.
As you can imagine, if you actually
understand what I just said,
it leads to a lot of tough conversations
and a lot of conflict
and a lot of being very careful
and threading the needle very carefully.
At the end of the day, for me personally,
I was always in a position
in the family business
where I was making the
core operational decisions,
so I had to put the logo
ahead of anything else in the micro.
I was was willing to shut
down the fuckin' business
if I thought it was going to undermine
my family relationship
of my brother and my dad,
but on a day-to-day basis in the micro,
I always pushed for the
thing that I thought
was best for the business, got it?
Think you have what it
takes to make it to the top?
It's time to make your pitch.
Step in, and step up.
Because your window of opportunity
isn't the only thing that's closing.
I'm so good at it, I'm so good at it.
(inspirational music)
Just real quick 'cause there's
a lot bubbling up of like,
Gary, you're pushing
people to work too hard,
and all this stuff and I'm watching
and I'm like, I love when elitists
who work their faces off
to make a bunch of money
then tell everybody else not to work hard.
(inspirational music)
So, to me, if you love what you're doing
and you're happy, and you're mentally
and physically healthy, do you,
I'm not judging anybody
about doing anything,
but, it's all about self-awareness
and putting a framework around where
you don't keep up with the Joneses.
(inspirational music)
- I know you get a lot
of criticism for it,
I get a lot of criticism
for how many hours I work,
and I'm like, mother-fuckers,
are you not listening?
Here's the punch line.
- Happiness.
I work that hard because I'm having fun.
I don't want to go skiing, dick face.
I do not want to go skiing.
I do not want to go to a beer garden.
It is not fun for me
to go look at a museum.
I am not interested in watching Netflix.
I am not interested.
That doesn't mean that I think
everybody else should do that.
I think, and I've said consistently,
self-awareness, happiness.
I've said it a million fuckin' times.
Do I believe in hustle?
Yes, I do.
I like work ethic, it's controllable.
Do I want that to put you into depression,
or health scares?
Yeah, of course not, dick face.
But don't sit on a pedestal after
you fuckin' worked hard for 15 years
and then tell all these
kids that they should
have a work-life balance,
you fuckin' elitist.
(inspirational music)
- Once you understand that in your life,
mother-fuckers, you're either going to be
chasing money or you're
gonna be chasing fulfillment
and nary the twain shall meet,
when you chase fulfillment,
you may also build a
massive fuckin' company.
- I'm gonna do both.
I always say, and I'm making up the rules,
that I'm gonna be the best entrepreneur
because I'm gonna make the most money
and have the most impact
on other entrepreneurs.
(inspirational music)
I only talk what I live.
I hate when people work
11 years on their startup,
work their faces off, I watch them grind,
and then they hit and then
they're sitting on money
and they're in that part of their life
and the advice they're
giving isn't what they lived.
I wanna hear from people publicly
that made 47,000 a year their whole life
and are happy as shit.
Go talk about that.
We're talking about happiness.
People are using mental health as a weapon
to make themselves look
good, just like non-profits.
You might be trickin' the 99%,
but you're not trickin' the 1%, partner.
(inspirational music)